bracken and Radner sure homes that
Brecon Beacons offers Dyk and more sheep
than people it's larger than any other
seat in England and Wales but this rural
constituency is about to pose a major
headache for the next prime minister
just a week into the new job when voters
go to the polls in a by-election the
Conservatives could lose the Tory
candidate Chris Davis won here with the
majority of eight thousand last time but
a by-election was triggered after he was
found guilty of making a false expense
claim what I did was make a mistake in
my admin I clearly that was nearly four
years ago as a new MP there was no
financial game there was no financial
intent to gain and it was purely an
admin error the brexit party is hoping
to capitalize in an area that voted out
Roger Ferrara asked me to stand in this
by-election and I wouldn't have said yes
unless I thought we had a reasonable
chance so but we'll see the Liberal
Democrats are well prepared they've been
working on this for ages but I think
we've got a reasonable chance and
they're getting good reception on the
doorstep it's a constituency that labour
has recently struggled in pushed into
third place last time some Labour MPs in
your party who suggested that Jeremy
Corbyn is a hindrance on the doorstep
how does it go down in this constituency
I think we're their new leader there is
obviously the section of the public that
don't get on with them and do get on
with them that's the same similar story
that we've been finding there's a lot of
support for him out out there and very
few who aren't that king there are some
but then we had that with Edie Miliband
Gordon Brown Tony Blair it is the same
situation
the clear challenges and frontrunners
are the Liberal Democrats they held this
seat between 1997 and 2015 and their
candidate is keen to make sure the
campaign isn't all about brexit I want
out I gotta be honest but local I vote
for you because I want you by one
Liberals
I want Lee Bruce here like it has been
in the past
Jane daughters chances have been boosted
by the decision by plied Camry and the
Greens to stand down and support her
candidacy as part of a remain alliance
we really welcome their decision to
stand aside it's very courageous thing
for them to do and we can see that
potentially this may be something we can
look at going forward that there may be
an opportunity to talk on other
progressive issues in the future so you
be happy to see live down standing down
in other seats then we will see as we
move forward my concentration here is on
Brecon and ravisher so what do people in
Bracken make of this controversial
by-election I don't think that the
Tories should be standing at all with
their current candidate because he
forged the expenses absolutely yeah so
yeah just hope that people vote
tactically whether they're Lib or labour
I think we just got a vote liberal to
get the Tories i poly Lib Dems are going
to get in yeah I don't think Labor's
ever gonna get in here because more like
a conservative but I think brexit pie is
going to do quite well here which is
concerning for me because I'm like a
Labour you can be waitin for labour
moping democracy as service basically
and that means that a vote that was
taken two and a half years ago news
three years goes on it because that's
what's needed in this country at the
moment there's a democracy deficit it's
about time put that right you mean Breck
said fundamentally yes brexit needs to
be delivered what happens here in Brecon
matters it could reduce the fragile
conservative what the majority to just
three and if the remain alliance is
successful it could be a blueprint for
an election that could come sooner
rather than later so if you Ridge Sky
News well a total of six candidates are
standing in the bracken and Ratna sure
by-election on August the first Sky News
we'll have the results and bring
reaction on the day